ces heurts lundi johan terrain quittait
son travail plutôt pour rejoindre ses
coéquipiers à l'entraînement spécifique
est la venue de toulouse oui on va le
revoir en vidéo et tirent quasi jamais
il est le seul joueur de l'élite à avoir
un autre emploi un musée ou cavalli sept
ans l'orléanais a vécu toutes les
montées est toujours alliée loisirs et
travail sort c'est un joueur avec qui
j'ai joué
il ya pas mal d'années donc ça nous
permet parfois de se retourner en se
disant voilà ce qu'on est devenu et
voilà d'où on est parti donc c'est assez
sympa et et d'ailleurs on remercie son
entrepreneur pour pour le libérer pour
l'autoriser à venir jouer puisque en
jouant le mercredi c'est pas pratique on
parle mardi on rentre le jeudi mais
voilà c'est une belle histoire je pense
le loisir hand est devenu un métier
l'entreprise c'est veolia
yoann ne fait partie de l'unité de
traitement des ordures ménagères travail
quotidien sauf les jours de match où il
prend des congés sans solde une envie un
choix validé par son employeur lorsqu'il
nous a proposé effectivement ce
challenge puisque c'est quand même un
challenge relativement important nous
avons trouvé
je vais dire un intérêt commun puisque
lui allait concilier à la fois le sport
de haut niveau et son travail
par certains aspects très contraignant
double casquette pour le handballeur
responsable de l'amélioration des
conditions de travail et de sécurité sur
le site il exerce une autre activité pré
physique c'est à partir maintenance donc
tout le citadin m'étonne donc aussi bien
électriques mécaniques hydrauliques
j'interviens peu sur tous les
équipements dont le dépannage préventif
et s'hydratent les séances ont 20 du
matin il n'est pas inactif pour autant
en temps je vais graisser les
ventilateurs de turenne
ils ne sont que 8 assurer la maintenance
d'où la nécessité de bien anticiper les
plannings avec des collègues
compréhensifs
c'est quelqu'un de courageux il est au
quotidien avec nous c'est pas quelqu'un
qui a la tête comme un melon donc il
reste à sa place au boulot il a sa place
et quand il se fait sortir outre ils ont
perdu un match en moins un petit peu
mais là ça va cette année ils sont pas
trop mauvais traditionnel bon de sortie
pour ne pas être en retard à
l'entraînement le dernier avant la
rencontre un quotidien très rythmé c'est
la course pour voir à l'entraînement
c'est le sport alors le sport mais on
arrive à faire une deuxième journée
commence
[Musique]